i mean obviously
much more light-spirited much more
pleased um we've seen the photos of
nazim on the plane um it's been a
long deal but obviously the last couple
of days where we've not been speaking
um it's been very up and down and it's
been getting closer and closer and
things moved on sunday uh so sunday's
wednesday got different parts
um and we've been bewildered ever since
trying to work out with this sort of an
incremental game of cat now still or
moving forwards um and we spent all
morning with a signaling airport um not
knowing what was going to happen um
probably to keep silence to everyone so
i mean a huge relief huge relief that
she's on a plane that she's coming home
that she's been and thank you
to everyone who's been helping along the
way it's been a long journey that people
have been keeping us
following it on the news
petitions with the government
i've said some rough things over the
years
but in the end
to all of us here it feels like a moment
in history but what does this mean to
your family well i suppose that we can
stop being a man which in history and
start being a normal family again
um yeah it's been a long time
we were just saying you know last night
gabrielle was asking is mommy really
coming back tomorrow well i don't i
don't know for sure i think we're closer
um i mean i now know
pretty surely she's coming home
and of course
you know it's a happy sunny day it's
also there'll be plenty of rain to get
through and um
six years apart there's a long time for
any family it's not something right have
you spoken to her on the phone she said
i've spoken
so she
got picked up this morning at 11 o'clock
run time um which will be 7 30 out of
the morning by the revolution regarding
that point she wasn't really allowed to
speak she had a phone with her so she
could send messages so
i knew where she was at different points
at some point she could speak to
somebody
what's the first thing you're going to
do as soon as she's back in your arms
and back with your family yeah well i
mean probably a couple of days peace and
quiet somewhere else and then back here
the first thing she always wanted to do
was to
me make a cup of tea
i think actually we were looking at the
house but it needs a bit of tidying as
well so there might be a bit of tiding
perhaps directed by humble when she
comes back and obviously there's a huge
amount of money that has been you know
forged over
what's the kind of conversations that's
been going on about that how do you feel
about the amount of money that's been
handled
so we we've we've obviously been kept
out of the loop and at various points
i've been talking the same listing
behind closed doors with the lawyers we
were checking while he's here
so i i don't i don't know what's
happened i've seen briefings before them
i mean i'm relieved for the proper
results
i think
the government has two jobs to protect
people in situations like this to make
sure it doesn't happen again part of
that is to doing what you need to do to
get people home and part of that is to
making sure those who took off learn the
lesson not to continue doing that um
that second part is for another day
but for today i'm really glad the way
things are people have really praised
your campaigning and you've spent years
you know fighting for this let's make
your recent hunger strike what do you
want to say to people who have looked
behind you well just thank you you know
we wouldn't have thought hey this
wouldn't have happened today without all
the carers the support of people up and
down the country that's you know
ordinary people important people people
in the media people in politics um some
celebrities but just
the overwhelming care we've had and i i
remember saying this on the hunger
strike it has been a cruel experience in
some ways but it also has been an
exposure to such a level of kindness and
care from all walks of life so
i am deeply grateful to everyone that's
got husband home it's got anasha home
it's got morado to furlough arsenal
fellow and all of the others who are
left there and thank you for everyone
for just seeing the world should be
different and finally how's
yeah pretty um pretty pretty uh agitated
as the day went on um i mean anxious
it's been bumpy you know there have been
some sort of
i know scary conversations in the last
couple of days as well of people just
trying to you know make sure that she
would be well behaved when she came back
um
on her face in that photograph
um
it's going to be lovely to see her will
be lovely
we've chosen which toys we're taking so
that you can see them um
but we live in the future
we've followed your journey generally
closely over all these years
will that first hug make all this
hardship worthwhile i'm not sure if it's
all worthwhile i mean
i i think
you know it's gonna be the beginning of
a new life um
a normal life uh hopefully and there'll
be bumps no doubt and
all the normal squabbles we have before
um but yeah i think we're really looking
forward to
seeing them as a dad myself i can't
begin to imagine how difficult it's been
all the false storms
when you got to break the good news to
your daughter that must have been a
special moment yeah i mean i think can
we still quite believe it i think when
we see mummy
and
you know it's it's certainly last night
and and then probably on sunday when the
passport came back maybe generally
picked up it's all that many mommy's
coming home i don't know what it is
realised
um yeah i think it's gonna happen
i think really grateful to all of you
that have followed us along the way and
you kept supporting them and captured in
the summer um which is crucial in cases
like this
um
but yeah i i think i don't i mean
homecoming's a journey on arrival i
don't think it will just be today there
will be a whole process um and hopefully
we'll look back in years to come and be
a normal family and
um you know this will be a chapter in
our lives if there are many more
chapters to come but we're delighted
with
thank you
congratulations
and thank you thank you also
i mean i should say
to the government to all the follow-up
staff
you know and we've had lots who've
helped us along the way behind closed
doors sometimes i've been very very you
know blunt in public and something
public but the care and the support the
foreign officer providers that different
ministers have at different points and
that
you know different members of my money
have um
you know it's been a tough journey for
all of us for lots of different reasons
and i'm really grateful for the grace
and the patience and the you know the
stoicism